en reino unido- largas filas en las
gasolineras y escenas de caos inéditas
entre el 50 y el 90 por ciento de las
estaciones se encuentran sin combustible
después de que una escasez de
transportadores desencadenará compras de
pánico algunos han manejado horas sin
encontrar un lugar donde adquirir
combustible ha sido muy duro temprano
por la mañana me levanté y trate de ir a
la estación de combustible y de asda
estaba vacía luego otras dos vacías esta
es la cuarta y no tengo combustible y
casi me voy a quedar sin así que no sé
cómo voy a llegar
no puedo creerlo es una locura parece
que no hay y siguen diciendo que no hay
escasez pero supongo que todo el mundo
está entrando en pánico ahora
las nuevas normas de inmigración tras el
prestige implican que los ciudadanos de
la unión europea ya no pueden trabajar
sin visado en reino unido lo que desató
una escasez de camioneros para el
transporte del combustible la
administración del primer ministro boris
johnson trata de tranquilizar a la
población wow bueno solo podemos seguir
asegurando a la gente que tenemos mucha
gasolina tanto almacenada como saliendo
de esas refinerías la única razón por la
que tenemos un problema en este momento
con algunas estaciones de servicio es
que la gente está comprando gasolina que
no deberíamos
el gobierno puso a el ejército en estado
de alerta para suministrar el
combustible a partir de este martes si
fuera necesario y anunció un plan para
expedir visados temporales a 5000
camioneros y mitigar la situación